I have MS and trigeminal deregalgia, which module is best?
Seven stages, which course is best?
So I think that's what you're asking, is the seventh phases of detox the best course?
No, I would say chronic disease in autoimmune would be the best course because MS is an autoimmune disease.
MS is, you have antibodies to myelin sheath cells.
So now you have an autoimmune destruction of your myelin sheath.
So MS is a demyelinating disease.
And the rate of demyelination is going to be dependent upon the rate of destruction.
And the rate of destruction is going to be dependent upon you getting a handle on,
what are the triggers in the immune destruction of the myelin sheath cells?
So go back to what I just said about autoimmune disease.
If you have antibodies to myelin sheath cells, you need to find out what's triggering your immune response.
It could be what I just mentioned.
I'm taking a bunch of immune stimulants because my naturopath told me to take it or I read that this is good for it.
That's really absolutely the wrong thing to do.
So no, wait, let's say another patient, I'm not taking any of that stuff, you know, I'm not doing any of that stuff.
Well, if you're stimulating your immune system in another way, maybe like eating a food that you have antibodies against.
So let's say you have antibodies against gluten and you're eating gluten.
It's stimulating the immune uptick and you're destroyed more myelin sheath cells.
So very destructive.
So you got to find those triggers and I go through that in, you know, I know I see a lot of course.
So I think that would be the best course to say try geminal neuralgia is different.
So try geminal neuralgia is not a disease.
So try geminal neuralgia is an inflammation of the tri geminal nerve.
The tri geminal nerve is your cranial nerve that controls part of the motor function of your face.
It can be extremely painful.
There are many different causes to it.
So it's not a disease that has a just one cause.
There can be many different scenarios that can be, you know, has to do with inflammation from again from a secondary autoimmune disease like MS.
Yes, you could have inflammation due to, you know, from a chiropractic issue with your cervical spine.
You could have inflammation due to this is a myriad of different things.
So digging to find out what the cause of that inflammation isn't calling me that down is going to be key.
Over the years, I worked with multiple tri geminal neuralgia patients from a functional structural point of view.
They had great success.
So you want to address it from a structural point of view in a laboratory point of view in autoimmune point of view.
If you're going to have good success, I would not suggest the detoxification course.
I'd suggest the autoimmune course.